[Applaudissements]
On Me demande souvent dans les lettres
commenter écrit une chanson commenter
la composer alors évidemment Je vais pas
faire l'historique de tous les
chansons que j'ai écrites mais IL y a
une chanson que j'ai écrit d'une Mani un
petit peu paruli IL s'agit de la Ville
Lila c'était un jour ou Alice et Moi sur
on cherche vainement l'inspiration et Au
bout de 3 he de secheresse tout d'un
coup Je dit écoute regarde le tableau le
tableau qui est juste sur Face du piano
chez Moi et Je essaie de composer
quelque chose dessus Je vais essayer de
trouver les paroles et tout
résultats dans la Vila
[Applaudissements]
dessous
l'arbre une robe
bleu
robe en coton
Rouge sous un ciel
d'hiver entre gris d'hiver
OMS
nuage et qui pleure
moitié derrière
l'arbre un bou
d'horizon Au
lointain pas même une
église
juste une
[Musique]
Maison est-ce leur
Maison ou bien
celle
des
nous
c'est la vie
lilas fait maison
métamorphose c'est la
vie à quand il me manque quelque chose
dans cette
Je vois que tu n'es pas pas
l et que pour ere moins
triste je détaille le
peinture
[Musique]
l'artiste et ma
la chambre devient le tableau
[Musique]
sous mois
pieds la campagne
Hum
de manger un
tapis de tête et de
pluie tout
l'heure elles vont s'y
verser plus longtemps
Mler ve bouger
bleu dans le lac
l'amour sans
rouler pour soi
consoler
J'ai abandonné par leur
menue
remplir
c'est la
[Musique]
vie fait de toutes ces choses c'est la
Voir quand IL me manque quelque chose
choisi dans cette
Vill o tu n'es pas
le o Je reste seul en
Pist c'est ma vie
[Musique]
Ila moitié bleu et moitié Rose c'est ma
Voir quand IL me manque quelque chose
choisi dans cette
[Musique]
via ou tu n'es pas
la et que pour utt tre moins
triste je retouche le
peinture
T
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'artiste